So I made a little Pinterest.
Look at my feet.
Are you joking?
I'm sorry. I'm sure everyone is already sick of this photo,
but I'm still here.
And, like, this has been so fun.
I literally never saw fat people on Pinterest growing.
I never saw people with curly hair
that would look up curly hairstyles on Pinterest.
It would all be like,
white women curl and not, like, natural.
I just, like,
never saw myself represented on Pinterest.
And I, like,
at my grown age,
I just get to be the representation that I wanted to be.
And I get to post these little pictures that are.
They're so Pinterest.
And, like, I don't care about likes,
I don't care about comments,
follows, literally anything.
I just care about making my feet, like,
a fun little place to share my fun little picture.
And I'm literally just, like,
having such a great time right now.
Maybe the time fixation will last for, like, five more minutes,
but, like,
I have maybe 60 pictures from this day that I still wanna post,
and then I'm gonna immortalize them on here,
like, on Instagram,
anything more than a single carousel post,
my photo shoot.
I'm like, okay, enough.
No one else wants to see that.
But here, I don't care.
No one follows me,
no one knows what's going.
I can spam, I can post as much as I want.
This is literally what I wish Instagram was just picture and fun.
I love everyone else is on Pinterest and I'm just late to the party,
but I think we should all be on this app.
Not enough, by the way.
Just so chill and fun and sweet and cute.
Trying desperately to convince all my friends to go.
And if you're someone who has a fun little Pinterest feed,
please let me know and share it below
cause I currently don't follow anyone.
He's having so much fun!
Okay. Anyways, yeah.